hi my name is John and this is Ari and
we were at IMAX's Technology
headquarters now we watch a ton of
movies and we especially love watching
them in IMAX but we also really like the
technology side of things so we crashed
on Macs in hopes that someone will be
nice enough to show us some of the
behind the scenes stuff and how the
movie magic is made look what we found
it is the CTO of IMAX mr. Brian bonnet
Brian thanks again for having us I just
want to say IMAX looks like a really
cool place to work I can't wait to see
what you have in store for us today well
first let me thank you guys for coming
this is where we do all of our RDR
manufacture and our service of our
products and we're lucky we have some
fantastic engineers and scientists very
creative people and I always like to say
this is where the magic happens
well I can't wait to see how the magic
happens well let's go and start the tour
now I'll show you some of these really
top-secret cool things come on with me
all right Brian we're not random
warehouse a bunch of boxes and where are
we we're actually in the manufacturing
facility of IMAX this is where we build
the products test them and then we ship
them out to all our customers so I'm
telling us that every single projective
it's out
place yeah we actually shipped over 52
countries end of 2011 we were shipping
about six systems a week you get quite a
lot through and we've got massive
capacity to increase if we need to a lot
of the Hollywood filmmakers are really
getting turned on to the IMAX camera
technology what you're actually seeing
here is our 3d digital production camera
Michael won't you tell us a little bit
of the camera what's so special at this
camera well this is the first fully
integrated large format 3d digital
camera I mean say we've got both cameras
built in one box and we're previously
the cameras were separated and you had
to film through a book called the beam
splitter which is basically a mirror at
45 degrees and like a giant box right
the giant box and a giant miss Ivan made
it rather difficult for filming and very
cumbersome to travel with so this camera
here will be a very big advantage to
tell maker that that's it one of the
neat things about this camera because
it's a solid-state it actually starts
capturing before you start shooting so
before you push the shoot button it's
constantly cycling capture so if you're
trying to capture something in wildlife
so if you're waiting for the animal to
do something by the time they've started
doing it you push the button you've
missed it so it actually captures before
you push the button what you see is
definitely the latest but on top of that
we're now considering the development of
an IMAX 2d digital camera to supplement
our film based cameras and give the
filmmakers the ability to capture like
they presently do with IMAX film cameras
but in the digital medium for obvious
reasons that second half of the IMAX
experience is sound
our sound has developed again ground up
so these loudspeakers they're designed
by us in-house to work specifically in
the IMAX theater venue if a helicopter
is flying around the building you want
to hear it going in a circle around them
in IMAX because of the discrete
uncompressed sound coming out of these
things we can move the sound around
within the seating deck so that it gives
you the feeling that you're experiencing
it the way the filmmaker recorded it we
work with the filmmaker
to digitally remaster the sound taking
advantage of our high dynamic range so
you get this reality that you can't get
with other systems this is our prototype
laser projector and you can sort of see
here you got a blue channel of color you
got a green kind of showing through here
and you get a little bit of red showing
down there they all get combined and
they get fed through the optical engine
here out through the lens onto the
screen it's a crude prototype it's not
reflective of what we would productize
but what it does do is show proof of
concept and we use it as a testbed to
test out how far can we push the limits
of the system
well there you can see an image on the
screen yeah it looks crystal clear it
looks like we're actually seeing this
happen how do you notice the blacks are
really black it's super bright even
though we've got camera lights shooting
at it so are we are you being approached
by any filmmakers yet - I use this
technology with their films we have had
demos that we've done with key clients
Studios film makers and the response was
actually overwhelmingly positive more so
than we expected to get which is
wonderful
so does this actually change the way
that filmmakers shoot their movie it
gives them a great deal more latitude in
terms of brightness and contrast and
color saturation you know the the colors
that they're going to be able to see
here are broader than that which you can
achieve today with an existing xenon
based projector one of the most
important things for IMAX is our brand
and our brand clearly stands for quality
of presentation well with hundreds of
theaters around the world we've got to
find a way to ensure that they all look
and sound the same day in and day out
and that they don't fail this is our
Knox Center where we control this we
monitor every single digital system
every show of every system 24 hours a
day 365 days a year now one of the best
things about working for IMAX is they've
got their own IMAX theater so we're just
gonna kick back and watch the movies
love the faculty have their own theater
try this one all right good